[Music]
welcome everybody
um we're so excited that so many of you
are going to be able to spend a day with
us
um this afternoon maybe this morning
this evening wherever you're dialing in
from welcome welcome
this is the first in a series of events
focused on non-traditional applicants
and today we're going to be talking
about arts media and entertainment
all right so um i'm going to briefly um
introduce
the gsb community then we'll meet our
panelists um we'll have some
questions ready um that i've got ready
for our panelists and then we'll open up
to your questions of course together
um so spoiler
alert um the students
that you know tell me that the best part
of the gsb is the people
and the people come to gsp from all over
the country and all over the world and
from all
representing many many different
backgrounds and interests
so as you can see by the numbers here
there's no single path
to the gsb and you know today we're
going to focus on is if you came from an
arts media or entertainment background
we are here for you we welcome you um
we've got some awesome students and
alumni joining us today
i'm actually going to turn it over to
them so that they can quickly introduce
themselves so we'll start
with ali
hi everyone it's great to see you all um
i am actually a student right now i'm a
second year
at the gsb i'm graduating next week
um class of 20 2021 um and i
originally went to stanford for
undergrad as well
majored in biology um spent a couple
years working
in consulting a startup and then right
before the gsb i was at netflix working
in content strategy
and then after the gsb i'm going to be
working at masterclass
um in business operations
um how about helen that's what i see
next to my screen
hey everyone i'm helen um
class of 2019 before the gsb
um i worked at the national basketball
association
in the strategy group and then
immediately after graduating from the
gsb i worked at a startup called
the athletic which is a sports media
subscription
company and now i just started working
at
spotify i joined two weeks ago so
awesome exciting uh matthew
hey everyone i'm matthew i worked after
i graduated i worked at
riot games for five years on league of
legends i was a product manager there
i went to business school to
get to know the awesome people and
expand my career horizons after business
school i started
working at nvidia and their cloud gaming
team and then
after about a year and a half in video i
did a hard pivot to
self-driving cars at cruise automotive
awesome thanks nana leese
hi everyone um i'm natalie's um prior to
i went to stanford undergrad as well
similar to ali
um but i spent most of my pre-gsb
life um in los angeles i was signed to a
record label
had a song on the radio one on tour
started a record label
um and then you know kind of pivoted
into film
finance and then went to gsb after that
kind of
last several years have spent a lot of
my time in consumer health and wellness
and now i founded
a health tech company in the consumer
space as well
awesome and indra to wrap this up
hello um i am class of 2012.
i did my undergrad at winston in art
history
uh i spent some time
um i had trained as a ballet dancer
before college and went back and spent
some time
after graduating from undergrad and um
danced professionally
and then went into the fashion industry
and worked at
vogue magazine so from there i applied
to
gsb um and i
continued on in um
fashion after gsb i went into
um a late sort of mid to late stage
startup called moda operandi
um where i was gm and creative director
there um and after that was a
pres uh the u.s president of a um
international
fashion label called del poso that was
based out of spain and then
left about five years ago to start and
found my own
company in the consumer space in travel
goods
called parabelle and i've been working
in the sort of sustainable
um good space since then
awesome um so i think everyone's gonna
be wondering and we'll just start with
you indra since i we left off with you
um why when you were coming from fashion
what made you
consider business school and then why
stanford specifically
so it was really about expanding my kit
ultimately
and i knew that i had exposure in these
creative spaces
and that i wanted to go back to those
but i knew i could be more impactful
if i could balance out my toolkit a bit
and
sort of have i had heard the expression
uh
someone i work for had sort of an eye
for design and a head for business
and i thought if i can sort of mirror
that skill set that i can be more
impactful in this space
um and sort of take a non a less
traditional route within
a field um that you know sort of has the
creatives in the suits traditionally and
wanted to
sort of balance have a foot in each a
bit and
um ultimately i'm sure we'll hear this a
lot from
as a theme but this idea of an
entrepreneurial community and an
entrepreneurial business school
stanford was my first choice the moment
i got in
and at the time it was uh derek bolton
when he called me i like accepted on the
spot and was crying and all that good
stuff um so
i knew that i wanted to be in a
community that was creative
that had a lot of outlets and
opportunities to
while i was at school have exposure to
companies here that i could dip my
which i did my second year i ended up
working um at an early stage startup
founded by some older alums of gsb and
so really being in that creative space
using entrepreneurship as an extension
of my creative inputs but also that
obviously provided a great foundation
for whatever i would go to
awesome and similar natalies for you as
well you know coming from a very
non-business background what for you
what was it about business school why
were you even thinking about it and then
why stanford
yeah i mean i think um
i never thought early in my career that
i would
go to grad school at all um i
i intended on staying in in music
um and and in entertainment where
it's not a prerequisite at all and in
some ways
um you know for certain roles
it's almost a um
a barrier in some ways um socially
and um but when i kind of
i worked in film finance for two years
and i had a huge learning curve on that
side of things
and was sort of thrown in on the
business side and i thought you know
like
like indra really said you know i should
maybe think about this and expand my
toolkit and and
part of it for me was not just the hard
skills
but also sort of this confidence that i
was looking for
um to really like i felt like i was
going into
meetings and like kind of faking it um
until i made it and um and i really
wanted sort of
to attain the skills so that i i could
be more confident in those
um in those situations
and ali i saw you were nodding your head
when natalie's was talking to
you know for you know where you were
coming from in terms of your background
was it uncommon for people on your team
to have a business degree or
be pursuing an mba yeah no actually in
my team it wasn't that uncommon
even though i worked in entertainment
the team i worked with was very focused
in strategy so a lot of people actually
had
mbas that were more senior and a lot of
them saw it as pretty beneficial so i
think for me
um i had as i mentioned study biology
didn't really take any business classes
in college and didn't really feel like i
had a good
general management foundation so that
was a really big
reason for me to go to business school
to expand that toolkit like
everyone has talked about and then also
on the soft skill side
like think up more about leadership and
communication skills in a more
structured way
and stanford is so known for that and it
sells in a lot of ways for that
um so i was really excited to take a lot
of those classes
and matthew for you i'm just working my
way through first quickly
um when you you know in the world of
gaming
did did a lot of your colleagues and
team members
you know were they thinking about a
business degree and you know what
what made you sort of go down that path
and consider stanford specifically
yeah i'd say it uh it was pretty unusual
for people
my colleagues to go apply to business
school i applied
mostly because i well two reasons one
reason was i felt like i'd hit a wall in
my career
just doing sort of the same thing for
four years of
building a product roadmap pitching it
getting a team
delivering it post launch iteration
repeat and i was kind of getting tired
and saw man the next leap in my career
a lot of these job postings require an
mba and then the second reason was more
personal which was i had really
struggled
making and maintaining lifelong
friendships and close friendships
a lot of my friendships were more
superficial four years after college i
was like man i really didn't
keep in touch with many if any of my
undergrad friends and so some of the
classes like
touchy feely and just the very close
tight-knit community
uh really appealed to me as well
and then helen from a sports sports
background
yeah um i i echo everything that people
i've already said before about the soft
skills leadership development
um i think for me
i um it wasn't uncommon for people in my
group to have gotten an
mba because i did come from the strategy
group which is more of people from a
traditional business background um so my
group was ex-consultants and ex-bankers
and i did actually do investment banking
prior to joining
the nba so i did have like that
quote-unquote traditional background
um as well um
so i mean frankly for me it was a two
years to recharge
to really focus on personal development
um travel uh
have fun make lifelong friendships um
which i definitely did um
so yeah and i think for me it was also
more of a long-term investment i
knew i wanted to go back into probably
more of a corporate type of world or
startup but like i didn't want to i
didn't have a desire to be an
entrepreneur or anything like that so i
knew i'd have i would have to
in some ways climb a corporate ladder
and i just think thought as a
as a woman wanting to be in a leadership
position in the future
having a gsb degree cannot like no one
can take that away from me and it's
a very valuable thing to have in the
future so
um yeah i think those are my main
motivations for
going to business school and then
choosing the gsb
wonderful um so for matthew natalie's
synindra
um you know how do you feel like your
background
or experience you know especially if you
didn't come from strategy
didn't have this maybe the quantitative
background that a consulting or you know
finance major
did or business major did um how do you
think that that factored into your
application as well as then your
experience um
once you got to campus
does anyone want to jump on that one i
can chime in
um certainly because i didn't have that
finance
i mean i worked in film finance but i
think in i paid more attention
i think um the first year where you have
sort of your foundational classes so
you have your you know accounting and
your traditional finance classes
um i definitely you know i think whereas
other classmates who had that experience
were like yeah i can do that like not a
big deal
um i literally uh like studied a lot
and so i think that played into my
experience um
and i think um you know it's their
skills that
i've i've utilized certainly in the last
few years
so certainly been helpful
so i'm happy to jump in here i really
came with no
background in in not in finance not in
consulting
i think i could do autosum on excel
because i had done that for
a boss before and sort of like tracking
people attending events
but really i mean but i
i was very transparent about it it
wasn't about i felt like i needed to
misrepresent
or augment who i was in any way
i was like i'm i'm a ballet dancer i'm
coming from this sort of fashion media
landscape
but this is what i want to learn and
this is why i want to come and and
there's a very real
use case for me coming and learning
these skills and this is how i can apply
them
so there was no expectation that i had
to
have those and i felt like the school
and the community and the admissions
office were very
supportive of that and even through my
experience
while at gsb and even after now there's
a lot of interest in learning
and hearing about experiences from
people who came with
really nothing um in terms of these sort
of quantitative skills and what that
looks like
and how to better and i think the
school's always looking to learn and
have a dialogue
um with those students and it's really
it's manageable yes
it's more work for the when you're going
through especially the
quantitative heavy quarters um
but that being said i felt like
while that those were harder for me and
i had to put in extra work
my classmates were so great about
helping um
people are so it's such a community
oriented mindset around learning that
i never felt like i couldn't ask someone
a question
um or ask someone for extra help or
find other classmates that had similar
backgrounds
than i did and sort of pulled together
to learn together and help
our you know get through some of my best
friends in the world are still some of
those classmates that those friendships
that i developed early on that were
coming from similar backgrounds and
we were navigating sort of what felt
intimidating at the time but in reality
wasn't and we were just
um pleasantly surprised by how
supportive everyone was
and then i felt like i you know just
like anyone coming in with different
skill sets you have something to add it
maybe in base finance i wasn't i didn't
have the most to add but when it came to
um like consumer behavior or something i
you know
courses that i felt like i had more
intuitive experience in i had word out
so it all
it's not a competition of who can who's
the most quantitative it really does
it all sort of evens out when you get
there because everyone's bringing
different life experiences people wanted
to hear
about what i had come from and where i
was going and
you know so it really wasn't an issue um
and the community was very supportive
about it
um yeah i would say uh i
had i learned a lot in my first quarter
i had no idea how to read a balance
sheet
let alone what a balance sheet was i
probably
didn't know what liabilities really
meant and certainly didn't i i remember
asking someone
what a p l was uh for my application i
really leaned more into
the giving people joyside i had and the
company i got to work at before business
school was
was just an incredible ride in terms of
just explosive growth and
the scale of impact that i was given the
opportunity and so i i focus more on
those soft
wins like hey we you know brought
friends closer together
we designed apis and technology that
were really cool
even though they were in the video game
space um and so i i definitely leaned a
lot into that
when i got to business school i was a
little intimidated because yeah there
are a lot of consultants and
investment people and i was there like
one of two video game people uh but
it was i remember there's in you get in
squads when you get there of like six or
seven people
and one of my squad mates worked at
whiskey distillery for six years
and i i am a huge whiskey fan so it was
fun to like meet someone right off the
bat that was
you know similar to me that had no idea
what
what all these consultants were doing
let alone why a company would hire
consultants
um so yeah i got i got a lot of the
experience
even though i really did not have
many of those traditional skills and i
mean i
i'll say i had no problem socializing i
i think
the beauty of stanford's community is
just
that all of your classmates are there on
purpose
and uh yeah i
i'm yet to meet someone i didn't enjoy
having drinks with
so um
quite this is actually piggybacking i'm
moving on to the actually open questions
now from
our um attendees but following up on
that um
question for everyone really but
specifically indra or matthew or
natalie's
if you are not coming from a business
background how did you prepare for the
application process
in their specifically talking i think
about the gmat exams
um they talk about essays too but did
you do you have any
any pointers there any guidance
i'll say i uh was a little unusual
applying for business school
i found out that my company was being
fully acquired
in like late november early december and
started studying for the gmat that night
because i
didn't know how i would pay for business
school so i had like two weeks to take
the gmat
uh i would highly recommend the
economist gmat prep
it's quite pricey but it worked really
well
on like it's just it was a great thing
to have on my phone on my commute or
random little you know waiting for a
meeting to start knocking out
five questions uh i i found that very
helpful and then
for my uh references or
recommenders um you know having an
honest conversation with them about hey
like i'm
are you good to recommend me for this um
rather than just you know firing off an
email
yeah i would echo that um in terms of
preparation
you know the gmat i had to remind myself
for the quantitative portion of it
around some of the sort of basic
equations that probably everyone needs
to review you know basic some of the
things for gmat anyway so i would sort
of do
courses or sort of i don't actually
remember the
the name of the program i used but i
would come home from work and i had sort
of a schedule for myself i'd come home
from work
and have dinner and sit down and like
give myself two hours
every night to sort of or whatever it
was also compressed time that i decided
to apply on so
i'm just taking a lot of the practice
tests and learning
learning the formulas and and then it's
really just about familiarizing yourself
with the primary um
the primary concepts from a quantitative
side and there's also
you know it's not all one thing i
learned coming from a non-traditional
background and taking the gmat going to
business school is not
going to like quantitative school that
management
and is is is an art and a science and
it there's there's a reason why there's
a verbal portion of the gmat and there's
a reason why
people from all kinds of backgrounds
come it's because
it's there's a lot of skill sets
involved in it i think there's a
focus if you're coming from something
that you don't know for example
quantitative that that will be some sort
of barrier to entry but
in fact it's just one of many skills
that you study and learn about
and that you need and sort of now as a
founder and a manager
a lot of the skills that i lean on
heaviest are the skills that the softer
skills that i studied
at business school um and so i find that
yes you want to nail those down you want
to familiarize yourself with the
concepts but
in terms of skewing your application or
your essays or any sort of preparation
towards you know proving yourself
outside of being able to grasp
and handle these concepts is not that's
not what you're being evaluated on i
think i mean
i'm not here from the admissions team
it's just from a lot of this
my classmates that i met that were from
amazing backgrounds
people had a variety of skills and
that's what made the community so
magical um and so that's just one of
many things and so
um that's what i would have told myself
at the time is to not fixate so much on
quantitative because you're being
evaluated as a person
and so yes familiarize yourself with the
concepts but when you're applying when
you're writing essays speak from your
heart and speak to what you're
passionate about because passion
is arguably just as important as sort of
being able to handle a lot of these
basic
skills and and now listen even
helen too actually if you guys want to
address um when you were approaching
your managers
especially in non-traditional industries
that are you know um
were you worried that the manager would
take that the wrong way or not know how
to write a letter of recommendation
um you know any guidance for how to
coach basically you're
you know coaching up um when you're
wanting to pursue
a business degree yeah so i
um just in terms of the recommendations
um you know there's not many people to
go to um i think when you're sort of
in sort of this untraditional world um
but i did ask my my creative manager
um and he had zero idea um
in terms of you know how where to start
but i you know we had a
at length conversation where we just
talked about
you know maybe points of of
um points of inspiration maybe
and um just kind of meaningful moments
that we've had
together and um i think that really
helped
him kind of shape like what he wanted to
say
um but i wanted it to be authentic i
wanted to you know come from him
obviously
um and then in terms of the other
references um i had asked
you know other creatives that i had
worked on projects with you know
and in some senses in some sense that
they were you know colleagues and not
it's not like i was necessarily
reporting to them but
i chose people who were um
would just have something meaningful or
thoughtful to say
yeah um a few things that i usually
uh advise people when they're applying
to business school in general
um whether you're a traditional or
non-traditional
applicant i would say i'm a mix of the
two um
i think having a a clear
thought and it doesn't need to stick but
having put thought
and be able to articulate why the gsb
and why business school makes sense for
you
in the next step of your career is will
resonate a lot with
you know yourself because you don't want
to waste your time going to business
school but also will
show that the admissions team like that
you've put thought in that this that
going to gsb will
elevate your career or make sense for
the next step
i think in terms of the application a
few things
um one i think you don't want the
application to be repetitive
so i found that for the
references if there were things that i
had done and i didn't want to talk about
it or didn't have space to talk about it
in my essays
i would suggest my reference pointed out
and say like i worked on this project
with you
can you highlight my impact on it or et
cetera et cetera so i like so i didn't
have to write about it and that you can
hear from him
the impact that i had so tactically what
that meant for me was like i thought
about my application very holistically
what i could put in my essay what i
could put in all the short answer
um pieces because the application has a
lot of short answers and then
what the my reference letters could
could accent and i didn't want it to be
competitive so i'm talking about the
same project and everything or anything
like that because then it's not adding a
lot of layers to you
um and then for me also tactically for
the
references i would suggest and i had
like bulleted out
reminder here are the things we worked
on reminder here's what i did
um and reminder here's the impact i made
but had him or her
write about it in their own words
because you obviously want them to be
like when natalie said be able to show
that you had meaningful impact and would
be able to really speak to
what you did and then lastly one piece
of advice that a
previous gspr told me when i was
applying was
for the what matters most essay um
it's an essay where when you write it
and you leave it like on the printer
at the office back when we would go in
the office
um and you've already left for the day
but you've printed it and it's like on
the printer you would go back and get it
because it's so personal and so
thoughtful and everything like that so
you wouldn't want like a random person
reading it so
um take that for what it is but those
are my
general application um pieces of advice
now i think that those were all great um
great tips i hope everyone was taking
notes
no i'm kidding you don't need take notes
um we have some questions here
that i'll pose to ali around sort of the
curriculum
and the gsb experience academically in
terms of how did it prepare you
for your career
goals if you want to take that one and
if anyone else wants to chime in
sure i would say um the curriculum as
some others have described
the first year is really focused on a
lot of the core classes so your finance
your accounting marketing operations
a lot of foundation in the second year
you spend a lot of time on
it's kind of make your own adventure you
choose the electives that you
wish to take and there's a lot of
classes that i think has have helped me
so far in my internship and in the job i
have now after graduation
like one for example i learned how to do
financial modeling i didn't know how to
do that
very well before school and that's a
very tactical skill i learned at the gsb
um through this class called managing
growing enterprise we focused a lot on
people management so
how to give feedback to a direct report
how to
um how to hire how to think about like
big business decisions and that i feel
like i've applied already
um in a lot of work already and there's
a bunch of other classes i would say
touchy-feely
you apply every day in your
relationships and at work
um there's a class called formation of
new ventures that really helps you think
about
whether you want to start a company and
become an entrepreneur and what that
would look like
um and i can keep going with a bunch of
other classes but yeah they've
a lot of them have been very tactical
and i can see the through line on how i
can apply them later
um some questions here about pivoting
and career trajectory i'm going to try
and
sum them up into one question um so for
those of you who are coming in
from very different backgrounds valley
dancing music
when you came in were you thinking that
you were going to
stay did you know you want to pivot and
then how did the gsb
help you in terms of resources
um you know how did your goals shift
while you were
you know during your two years here um
and you know how did how did gsp prepare
you
for for your next step
yeah i'll jump in i would say um
uh for me i when i left business school
i was planning on going back into gaming
and did for a little while
and thought a lot about i i also did my
uh
my summer internship in business school
was in video game venture capital which
was
very fun and very different for uh me
um just you know having been an operator
my whole career going into the investing
side was quite interesting
um and i was not having the best time at
nvidia had decided i was going to
leave and was trying to sort of figure
out do i want to stay in gaming or not
and for me business school really helped
me make the pivot i had taken
a class from a professor i'd really
enjoyed i took public policy
uh with keith hensey and then he did
another class
on autonomous vehicles and the impact
they were going to have
and one of my classmates sent out to
uh you know each class has like their
little communities we have a whatsapp
group
sent out job posting that cruz was
hiring and
uh yeah i was like great i love
self-driving cars i think they'll change
the world
uh i think that had i not gone to gsb i
wouldn't have had the confidence to
know that hey you're a gamer but i can
still succeed in
uh you know a way more serious company
than video game company
i would just echo one thing that matthew
said that i think is really key
um and i hear this from a lot of alums
especially from non-traditional
backgrounds
is this idea of giving you confidence to
pursue things that maybe you thought
were outside of your wheelhouse or
outside of
your expected career trajectory
and you know entrepreneurship is just
one example of that but i saw people
pivot in a lot of unexpected directions
and i think the beauty of spending two
years
on that beautiful campus with
a beautiful community is this not
needing to know
exactly what you're going to do when you
come out and i think giving yourself
that space is an important part of the
process
because i think people who got the most
out of it were people who were kind of
open to
i might go back but i may try something
new i saw that
from all sorts of you know i saw people
who thought they were coming from
consulting going back into consulting
and
really took a left turn and then you
know i saw people coming from
non-traditional backgrounds going into
sort of
very finance driven back you know every
every version of that and i think that's
one of the most rewarding parts of this
two years
wherever you're coming from is that
opportunity to sort of
try things got try things outside your
comfort zone you have to somewhere in
between
to sort of test out a thesis you can um
like i mentioned i i sort of was working
part-time at a startup during my second
year because there's so many outlets to
experience that in the bay area that
it's very convenient and a lot of people
did that
with jobs or internships um freelance
work so
i found that a big plus
and then also this idea of confidence so
now i you know am
a founder of a company and there are
many times where i went and
was pitching a concept to a potential
investor or potential partner where
just just sort of having a lot of the
exposure to a lot of the courses in
community i've had over time gave me
sort of the feeling that i have a
voice in this room and that may be
sort of a very abstract notion but it's
something that has served me in my
career
um and allow me to take more risk
um and i think that that is one of the
biggest benefits for me personally
yeah i'll i'll add on to what indra said
i think um all of that
um is true for me as well i think um
entering business school i
said to myself like in my mind i thought
yes there's definitely
like a a path that um for me to go back
to music but i really gave myself the
permission to say
to really reflect and and ask myself
what do i
really want to do um how do i want to
show up in the world how do i want to
operate in the world what kind of impact
do i want to make
in the future and and what does that
look like authentically for me
um and and i think just be such a great
environment to do that because the
professors um
the classes just the environment like i
think everyone is so encouraging of of
being
super honest with yourself
just to quickly add on about gsb
resources
um there's like
there's a few sports media entertainment
specific classes that i think anyone
that's interested in this industry will
take
and those classes are awesome we have
really awesome guest speakers
um which um it's just you know one of
the cool things about going to school
with the brand name
um you get like a paltrow to come to
your class tyra banks teaches the class
a-rod teaches a class like
those are all really cool um i think the
career counselors are i think
the career counselors are also really
helpful in terms of
for me when i told them what i was
interested in doing post business school
connecting me
with gsb years from the past who are in
the industry or work at companies that i
would be interested in
um because maybe they they are fresh on
the career counselor's mind and i would
never have known so the
i do the thing the alumni network for me
was instrumental in
um what i did post gsb in terms of just
learning about all the opportunities
out there i came from a strategy
background i said i wanted to work in
operations but like i actually had no
idea what operations
meant so it's really just talking to
alumni
who worked in operations across all
different companies to really understand
what they did
um and they would introduce me to other
alumni or other people so i thought that
was really helpful
and one of the great things about being
a student is that you can just ask for
help you can just ask for advice you can
just like email people for
coffee i thought that was for me one of
the more
helpful learning ways learning
opportunities
for my pivot
and actually piggybacking off your
comment about the career
the career office support there is a
question here from adam that talks about
if you can anyone wants to elaborate on
their recruiting experiences
at stanford gsb um so he's actually
coming from a sports media career
um and he's looking to go into consumer
products and tech um
and he's worried that lack of industry
experience will be a disadvantage
and so for you guys for those of you who
did we're looking at other things and
you know when during your first
and second year when you're like doing
your one-on-one advising with the career
counselors you know like
what um what was that experience life
and how did they how did they guide you
um ally i don't know if you wanted well
yeah
i i love our career counselors at the
gsb
uh my first session with one of them was
just sitting down and kind of ideating
you know what can a career look like and
what are three different paths i could
possibly take right after business
school and where do those lead
and i want that session was one of the
most helpful things i did in my first
year
and then after that she really connected
me to a bunch of alums who are doing
each of those things and so i could
start conversations
and then in terms of their recruiting i
would say really differ so if you are
doing recruitment for a very structured
um
organization kind of like consulting or
investment banking or
big tech companies there's a lot of
structure to the process you you know
when you need to submit your
applications who you need to talk to
if you're doing something that's a
little bit more open-ended
and you're just trying you know get to
know a startup that's a little bit more
early stage
it ends up being a lot more
informational interviews and you talking
to a lot of people and connecting with
alums
and and and there's less structure to
that process so it really depends on
on what you want to do um for your
internship
um great matthew i don't know if you
guys want to elaborate on
when you were working with the cmc you
know how they helped you approach maybe
those non-traditional careers then
in that path uh sure
i'll say i sort of went the alumni
network route i
knew when i went got to business school
that
uh i really wanted to use my first year
internship to try out
video game venture capital and worked
with the
and sort of crafting how do you actually
reach out to alumni with the high chance
of success
uh i think overall though the alumni
network is just such
uh just is very good
at responding and and being
communicative and and really
uh you know embracing the full broader
community of the gsb not just
your class in the class so right before
and after yours but
but that all alumni are here to help out
so i
i sort of more went that route when
trying to plan out my
post uh gsb career but um
yeah i mean i did a lot of interviews on
campus
a lot of the non-traditional people do
recruit on on campus
directly and i think that um you know
one of my good friends
uh helen and i were just chatting about
this in private messages but he worked
at the nba as well
and uh did his uh internship at
activision which is a video game company
and
him and i talked about that so i think
you get a lot of opportunities and
exposure to these non-traditional
backgrounds throughout the course of
school
yeah i also went the alumni route so as
i mentioned in the summer between my
first and second year i worked at a
startup
that i ended up working through all my
second year that was founded by alums
one was a year ahead of me one was two
years ahead of me and
um they had sort of we found each other
through the alumni network and
uh that sort of led to for the
conversation that exposed me to the
early startup
space in fashion and um i found
the alumni network really impactful and
and everyone's very open to helping
and shambhavi i think you you have a
question about what it you know does the
gsb assist in reaching out to the
um to the network or the firm so what we
typically do is the alumni you will find
that alumni are super responsive
as i'm sure all of these um panel folks
will agree
you you just email them cold email them
and they will respond to you and get
back to you
straight away um and then we do have
different forms
of on campus and you know off-campus
recruiting that can be done through
through the g specifically um we have
some
questions here that are directed at
specific panelists so i'm actually gonna
put you guys in the spotlight for some
of those um
so there was a question about um
dalton is also a ballet dancer and
he he's hoping to dance professionally
so curious to know whether or not it's
better to attend gcp right after
undergrad or take a couple years to work
first
so indra if you want to touch that and
then in general to sort of when you're
coming from
a creative background is it better to
have some work experience
so it's such a personal answer i think
there's no right or wrong way to do
any of this um so i'll caveat that and
just
share my experience i did take the time
after um undergrad to dance
professionally but i
was graduating from a ballet school and
was offered a
a job with a with a ballet company um
so it was really about navigating
different opportunities and what the
right time was to take each one
and how i spaced it out um you know
i did i love ballet still
and i took um ballet classes at
stanford while i was here the un you
know undergrad has
ballet classes and um a studio
so i was able to do that i was able to
attend performing arts in the space so
for to the extent that that that was
you know the extension into other
schools including undergrad is an
amazing
option you know i took photography my
second year
um with a mix of schools you know so you
really can
tailor especially your second year to
what
your passions and interests are um one
and you have this core foundation to
build on
um so it there really is no right or
wrong
time it's really sort of up up to your
sort of what you're what you're looking
to get out of it but um
to the extent that stanford is a great
place to continue developing
all of these passions i would say
absolutely because you have access to
everything
um and you know i would sometimes go
into san francisco to see the san
francisco ballet
just before performing and um there's
open classes in san francisco so
really just having an amazing
um sort of roster of opportunities if
you're still at a stage where you're
figuring out
what the next step is is
really a wonderful experience
um and natalie's beatrice um
is asking about your transition to
healthcare
so she is a medical doctor hoping to
venture into entrepreneurship and health
tech
well i can definitely say that in my
class we had
a few md mbas um and they
are thriving in sort of their kind of
entrepreneurial journeys
in the health tech space um you know my
this company that i founded is it's a
fairly
recent um startup uh we founded it last
year
um but you know i think
interestingly uh when i reflect back on
it my
internship between my first and second
year i worked for
a d2c sort of um a
beauty company which i know is not
health tech but certainly
in in my path was sort of a transitional
um it was a transition like uh
like you know um
point i guess for me that really helped
move me along
um in that path
um and then there's one here for
um matthew in terms of did you feel
did how do you think the gsp helped you
pivot into the industry
now um self-driving vehicles
yeah i mean
it's tough because my current role is
not
too different from a lot of roles i
think it
uh that i mean obviously keith has these
class autonomous vehicles helped me a
lot just to focus on
uh sort of develop a perspective on the
industry yeah
i knew nothing about it coming to
business school and and so
being able to at least say like okay i'm
confident that these companies are going
to be the winners in the space
i think helped me be confident applying
for
a pre-revenue company while also having
you know starting my family which was
a little bit challenging um but
i'd say the the biggest help for me was
just
yeah sort of around confidence in in
managing like learning how to manage
people and
and you know starting down the path of
growing my scope of influence i think
those
those types of soft skills translate
between a lot of different industries
but in the gaming industry
uh there are a lot of people who don't
have great soft skills in gaming
um and so i think having the background
at the gsb helped me a lot
um and ally so what has life been like
on campus
um this year and this is a question from
dean
and specifically asking about um covid
and
what the gsb has been like yeah a lot of
things changed understandably
um we i mean a lot of our events were
canceled or moved online
classes were moved online um and
right now i would say campus is starting
to come back now we have some hybrid
classes so we get to go to campus
and and do classes at six feet distance
um with masks on but i would say i still
feel like i got a lot out of the
experience the classes that still were
great online they
a lot of it changed the way that the
courses were taught the type the types
of small group activities we did
um but i the gsb made a lot of it work
um and i'm happy that right now we're
gonna have a graduation in person next
week so it's exciting to actually get to
celebrate the end of the experience in
person a little bit more awesome
um we have about five minutes left
so i thought i would go sort of round
robin
um to all the panelists and end
with any final sort of
thoughts tips guidance
best practices that you would advise for
those folks who are thinking about
getting
a business degree from stanford um
any sort of parting words
yeah i'll go i i'd say some great advice
i got both uh before applying and it
was given again by someone else uh after
uh getting in and accepting was to
really know what you wanted out of the
experience
i was very intentional about choosing
uh i i i went for personal development
you know i think for me the career side
was sort of a
uh more of of just getting the degree
and having that on my resume frankly but
the community side was why i was really
going to stanford in particular and what
i wanted to get out of it
and i think it helped me prioritize a
lot of the early decisions i had to made
make throughout the experience to ensure
that
i was getting the most out of out of the
experience
okay yeah i think to echo that
um i don't think there's a right or
wrong choice on where you decide to go
and apply but i think doing as much
due diligence as possible in terms of
what school you would
you know learn the most from thrive at
have the community that you want it's
it's all completely dependent on you and
your goals and
what you want out of the experience um
that really dictates whether or not you
enjoy that experience so
for me i think talking to as many
alumni current students as possible to
hear about their
individual experiences at their
individual business schools will help
guide you
in terms of deciding where to apply and
then ultimately where you go
i would go back to what i had mentioned
earlier which is this idea of
authenticity and
you know if you're given this group is
really thinking about the application
process
and you know this concern around will i
be quantitative enough or
will i be able to transition into the
right job it's really about showing
the admissions team who you are what you
care about
um not trying to present what you think
people are looking for because
we probably have and had no idea what
they're actually looking for we just
know what we
care about and by showing that
it's going to determine your best match
um the best match for you and so
really taking the time to sit with
yourself and figuring out what that is
for you
and then authentically translating that
um and you know we talked about
recommendations finding someone who
really knows you
not sort of someone who you think may be
impressive but not know you very well
i would imagine that it's more impactful
someone who can really tell your story
has really
worked with you in some capacity um so
just to
feel like when you're turning over that
application you're like this is me
um you know when helen had said that i
had never heard this the story about the
printer but the first thought when you
started saying that about like someone
finding the printer
i think the other side to that is like
someone picks it up and your name isn't
on there and they know that's you
right not like you know that could be
the other side equation something
personal but also like if i picked it up
and
no one knows who it is like but someone
knows you're like oh that's so you
and and finding that in yourself and
then being able to translate that
because
the school will respond to you know your
mat your match in terms of school will i
think come out that way
um and then once you're there um
having that same attitude of sort of
really showing up and being present
being open to all kinds of things and
really
not going into it with preconceived
notions about how you should
show up or shouldn't show up but really
just being open to it your classmates
are going to be amazing
um you're going to learn so much from
everyone around you and just sort of
being in sponge mode i think
it's it's something that i miss most
about
um sort of having laughter the community
is just
you just get to be a sponge all day it's
an amazing experience
um ally or natalie's any final
yeah i i can go nuts i i i really
completely with andrew was saying um
about authenticity and what i would add
to that is
the reflection i made when writing what
matters most to you and why
was really really valuable to me
personally so i would think of it as
like
broader than this application it's an
opportunity for you to think about your
life holistically
put a thread to your experiences and
really think about
what you want to get out of the next
five years 10 years
and i found myself using that reflection
quite a bit during my time at gsb and
even today in classes when i think about
my values and
so it's it's more than just an essay
it's an opportunity for you to have some
very valuable
self-reflection
um i'll say i'll add two things one is
if you're
thinking about applying but you're not
sure if this is you know the right path
for you
i will say that for me personally gsp
changed my life full stop
um in terms of my friends
um and certainly you know some uh
relationships that
um i really value um
and and just how i i operate in the
world how i think about um the future
um and how i want to make an impact
um number two i would say that for
untraditional applicants
i think and i think this is sort of what
other people have said
um but i think it's important so if you
do get in that
you're strategic about where you
um about where you want to go if it
in terms of whether it's three years
from now or five years from now
and sort of let that be sort of a
um an influence in how you
um how you navigate your journey
at the gsb um because i think that it's
more required i think for an
untraditional
applicant than for someone who's going
to return
to their industry
amazing thank you thank my all of our
panelists for joining us today
and taking time out of your busy
schedules thanks for those who were able
to
sit in and join us today um if you have
any questions
feel free to email our office anytime
always available for you
for you and you can always check our
website for
future events um and staying connected
with us so thanks so much and have a
great day